[Musik]
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ich darf sie bitten jetzt die plätze
einzunehmen herzlichen dank
haben
herzlich willkommen an der
theresianischen militärakademie zu den
ausmusterung feierlichkeiten 2020 zum
festakt tag der leutnant ich darf sie
bitten ihre sitzplätze einzunehmen
mein name ist thomas mittermeier
ich bin der kogit beauftragte der
theresianischen militärakademie und ich
bitte sie nachfolgende hinweise zu
beachten und einzuhalten
damit schützen sie sich selbst und die
anderen teilnehmenden an dieser
festveranstaltung halten sie mindestens
einen meter abstand zu anderen personen
und tragen sie immer einen mund nasen
schutz mit sich tragen sie einen mund
nasen schutz sobald sie mit anderen
personen in direkten kontakt treten und
dabei der mindestabstand unterschritten
wird
halten sie bitte die zugewiesenen
sitzplätze ein und wechseln sie diese
nicht
dies ist für eine allenfalls
erforderliches contact racing notwendig
vermeiden sie hände schütteln
verwenden sie beim husten oder niesen
ein taschentuch oder husten bzw niesen
sie in ihre kleidung oder armbeuge
keinesfalls jedoch in ihre hände
wenn doch waschen sie sich ihre hände
bei nächste möglichkeit vermeiden sie
das berühren von augen nase und mund
beobachten sie sich selbst und wenn sie
sich krank fühlen finden sie in
blickrichtung maria theresia rechts in
der wiese in anlehnung den stand des
roten kreuzes und wenden sich an diesem
wenn sie innerhalb der nächsten 14 tage
auf kubik 19 positiv getestet werden
informieren sie uns so bald als möglich
über die e mail adresse
müller ev.de v
at befolgen sie in weiterer folge die
anweisungen der moderation insbesondere
zum geordneten verlassen der
veranstaltung und setzen sie dabei ihren
mund und nasenschutz wieder auf ich
danke für ihr verständnis und ihre
mitarbeit und wünsche ihnen einen
wunderbaren festakt
werte ehrengäste angehörige der
ausgemusterten leitende sehr geehrte
damen und herren
seien sie herzlich willkommen zum
heutigen festakt anlässlich der
ausmusterung von 77 jungen offizieren 53
berufs offizieren und 24 miliz
offizieren junge männer und fünf junge
frauen die bereit sind verantwortung für
die sicherheit österreich zu übernehmen
mein name ist oberst paris trainer
fringer und ich habe die ehrenvolle
aufgabe diesen festakt zu moderieren
ich darf ihnen nun die aufstellung der
ausrichtende bekanntgeben
ich beginne dazu von mir gesehen aus
links anbeginn sehen sie die
militärmusik niederösterreich unter der
leitung von oberstleutnant adolf
obendrauf
danach die fahne der militärakademie den
fahnen und standarten blog des
österreichischen bundesheeres sowie das
ehren partei formiert aus den ersten und
zweiten jahrgang
ihnen gegenüber stehen die zu
übernehmenden berufs und militärs folgt
der jahrgang der region 7 mit
offiziersanwärtern aus bosnien und
herzegowina italien lettland litauen und
polen und anschließend die kadetten der
bundeshandelsakademie für führen und
sicherheit in wenigen augenblicken
erfolgt ein gruß der luftstreitkräfte in
form eines überfliegers die
luftfahrzeuge kommen von mir aus gesehen
links über das kinsky denkmal nach einem
ankündigung signal erfolgt die meldung
des kommandanten des akademiker
parteilos oberst er hat fleischmann an
den herrn bundespräsidenten
universitäts-professor professor dr
alexander van der bellen nach dem
abspielen der bundeshymne und der
europahymne erfolgt das abschreiten der
front durch den herrn bundespräsidenten
die frau bundesminister für
landesverteidigung magistra klaudia
tanner den chef des generalstabes
general magister robert brieger den
kommandanten der theresianischen
militärakademie generalmajor magister
karl braun tage sowie den bürgermeister
der stadt wiener neustadt sein
klubobmann und abgeordneten zum
niederösterreichischen landtag magister
klaus schneeberger
im anschluss erfolgt die große frage
habe
[Musik]
da
es erfolgt nun die begrüßung durch den
kommandanten der militärakademie
nach einem durch die militärmusik
intonierten choral hören sie die worte
der geistlichkeit
im anschluss daran erfolgt die ansprache
des chefs des generalstabes general
magister robert brieger der 92er
regimentsmarsch alle ehren ist
österreich leitet über zur ansprache der
bundesminister für landesverteidigung
magistra klaudia tanner
hoch geschätzte und festgäste sehr
geehrte berufs und milizionäre das jahr
2020 ist dort für die theresianischen
militärakademie ein jahr der
herausforderungen im umgang mit cookies
dennoch sind wir stolz neben unseren
bildungs und forschungsauftrag auch
unseren beitrag im rahmen der
assistenzeinsätze geleistet zu haben
einerseits durch den erfolgreichen
einsatz der militärakademie des
jahrganges des nunmehrigen burgherrn
jahrganges dragoner regiment 7 sowie
durch offiziere und unteroffiziere aus
dem bereich des stammpersonals für den
heutigen tag haben wir alle
anstrengungen unternommen und trotz
kogit 19
im rahmen eines würdigen festaktes 53
berufs und 24 die offiziere in das
bundesheer zu übernehmen der heutige
ausmustern jahrgang der jahrgang hat man
neues jahr hat gestern seine sponsion
zum bachelor of arts in militärische
leadership und den erfolgreichen
abschluss der drucken
offiziersausbildung mit der beförderung
zum leutnant begangen
wir sind sehr stolz dass unsere
ausbildung hochschulischen maß
stattfindet und auch international hohes
ansehen genießt dies zeigt einmal mehr
die anwesenheit treten aus bosnien und
herzegowina italien polen litauen und
lettland
gleichzeitig wäre aber ohne unsere miliz
aufgaben in und ausland in der
derzeitigen größenordnung nicht zu
bewältigen
so stellen unsere milizoffizier einen
integralen bestandteil unseres
offizierskorps sda
berufsarmee die offiziere haben eine
ausgezehrte die ausbildung erhalten mit
unterschiedlichen wegen aber einen
gemeinsamen ziel dienen
sie werden befähigt sein in ihren
künftigen verwendungen und funktionen
die verschiedensten militärischen
herausforderungen zu bewältigen und die
gestellten aufgaben zu erfüllen
mit dieser kurzen einführung zum
heutigen festtag dadurch sie särge
erdbeeren und festgäste zum tag der
leuten und 20 20 auf das aller
herzlichste begrüßt
wir bieten unseren respekt von bruce dem
herrn bundespräsidenten und unseren
oberbefehlshaber herrn dr
alexander van der bellen mit freude und
respekt begrüßen wir unsere frau
bundesminister für landesverteidigung
magistra claudia da jetzt begrüßen wir
den herrn bundesminister außer dienst
generalmajor magister thomas stahl
in vertretung der landeshauptmann von
niederösterreich begrüßen wir den
bürgermeister
unsere stadt total stadt wiener neustadt
abgeordneten zum die größten landtag
klubobmann magister klaus schneeberger
gemeinsam mit der dritten
landtagspräsidentin mal christa karin
renner
wir bieten unseren respektvollen bewusst
der hohen geistlichkeit herren
militärbischof dr werner freistetter
militärs finden wenn magister doktor
doktor reinhardts trainer herrn
erzpriester dr
dr dr alexander rabin sowie herrn
präsidenten yüksel bilden ein herzliches
willkommen denn wer sprechern und
präsentieren
abgeordneter zum nationalrat
vorsitzender des
landesverteidigungsausschusses und
amtsführender vorsitzender der
parlamentarischen bundesheerkommission
doktor einer dash sowie abgeordneten zum
nationalrat robert mayer
unsere spec voller gruß mit den
abgeordneten zu den gesetzgebenden
körperschaften dann abgeordneter zum
nationalrat und erster vize
bürgermeister dr christian stocker herrn
bundesrat martin predator abgeordneter
zionistischen landtag und klubobmann
reinhart grundmüller abgeordneter zum
niederösterreichischen landtag und
klubobmann rudolf bauer abgeordneter
ziemlich der istrischen landtag diplom
ingenieur franz den vogel als
ranghöchste offizier des
österreichischen bundesheeres begrüßen
wir unseren chef des generalstabes herrn
general magister hubert ringe aus dem
bundesministerium für landesverteidigung
begrüßen wir den staatschef der frau
bundesminister general mehr magister
rudolf striedinger in vertretung des
leiter sektion 1 general magister
magister halt wo das ekt in vertretung
des leiters generalstabs die aktion
general mir magister magister
alexanderplatz in vertretung des leiter
sektion 3
general mills der magister norbert huber
sowie in vertretung des leiters der 64
general magister dr hermann lotter kann
wie kommen wir dann vorsitzende des
zentralausschusses oberst peter schropp
visa sowie den vorsitzenden der punkte
sehr gewerkschaft ministerialrat
magister walter hirsch und mit ihnen
alle damen und herren der
personalvertretung kameradschaftlich
begrüßen wir stellvertretend für den
kantor streitkräfte dann general
magister robert berater sowie den mit
der führung beauftragten kannst der
streitkräftebasis bringe der magister
siegfried programm ganz besonders
begrüßen wir das unseren wirkungs
verbund der regierung schule einkommen
der landesverteidigungsakademie
generalleutnant ist er ja nicht fit kids
sowie den konten der harris und
offiziers akademie präsentieren die
kolosse herzlich willkommen herz wird
dann leiter der vertretung größten
generalisten und magister franz leitgeb
sowie die in österreich akkreditierten
verteidigungs militär und luft attachés
mit ihrem teuren oberstleutnant im
generalstab frank schönholtz
und so willkommensgruß gilt allen
leitern der enter den gruppen und
abteilungsleitung der zentralstelle der
miliz beauftragten der medea brigade und
patrons konten des österreichischen
bundesheers der landespolizeidirektor
von niederösterreich den präsidenten des
österreichischen roten kreuzes in der
bezirks und von wiener neustadt den
präsidenten der österreichischen
offiziersgesellschaft sowie der und
offiziersgesellschaft privaten der
waffen und fachschulen den
repräsentanten unserer garnisonsstadt
sowie den privilegierten uniformierten
bürgerchor und den repräsentanten aus
wirtschaft industrie handel und an
unseren kooperationspartnern im in und
ausland für alle angehörigen des
ruhestandes den ehemaligen
generalstabschef general magister edmund
entacher den ehemaligen akademie konnten
herrn general in ruhe minister karl
heinz vietze sowie den ehemaligen leiter
der einsatz sektion sterne general in
ruhe magister christian segur cabanac
abschließend gilt mein gruß allen
weiteren damen und herren die unsere
einladung gefolgt sind insbesondere den
angehörigen der heute im mittelpunkt der
feier stehenden offizieren und offiziere
allen welche den heutigen festakt
erstmals im livestream verfolgen
herzliche grüße aus wiener neustadt
herzliche grüße von der militärakademie
uns danke für ihr interesse am heutigen
tag denken die auch alle dienststellen
welche unseren langjährigen ausbildung
unterstützen und den heutigen fest werk
ermöglicht insbesondere der politischen
leitung im generalstab allen vertretern
des bundesministeriums für
landesverteidigung den streitkräften und
der streitkräftebasis für ihre
personelle und materielle unterstützung
sowie natürlich den waffen und
fachschulen
ich wünsche ihnen alles erdenklich gute
viel soldatenglück es lebe die
theresianischen militärakademie
[Musik]
es gibt für jeden monat einen eigenen
bibelspruch gewissermaßen als motto der
für oktober 2020 stammt aus dem buch des
propheten jeremia und lautet suchet der
stadt und des staats bestes und betet
für sie zum herren denn wenn es ihr wohl
eher geht
so geht es euch auch wohl er könnte
nicht treffender sein für euch und für
den heutigen anlass beide ebenen des
lebens werden angesprochen das
verantwortliche handeln in der welt und
an der welt das wissen dass es ein
eingebundensein in etwas größeres gibt
beim handeln gerade als offizier ist es
wichtig immer daran zu denken warum es
geht worum es geht nämlich um das wohl
des menschen und des landes um ein
segens volles handeln
dafür wünsche ich euch allen segen
liebe anzüge lobende leutnant möge gott
der herr euren friedensstiftenden dienst
in unserem österreichischen bundesheer
segnen
der vater der sohn und der heilige geist
armen schon vor mehr als einem halben
jahrhundert hat das zweite vatikanische
konzil die aufgabe der soldatinnen und
soldaten so beschrieben und ich zitiere
er als soldat im dienste des vaterlandes
steht betrachte sich als diener der
sicherheit und freiheit der völker
wer diese aufgabe recht erfüllt trägt
wahrhaft zur festigung des fritz bei
verantwortungsvolle und in vieler
hinsicht fordernde aufgaben erwarten sie
so ist es nur richtig und gut dass wir
um den segen gottes für sie bieten
der segen gottes möge sie begleiten das
wort gottes sei ihnen licht auf ihrem
weg
die namen des vaters und des sohnes und
des heiligen geistes
amen
hoch verehrter herr bundespräsident hoch
geehrte frau bundesminister geschätzte
jahren uns festgäste meine sehr geehrten
weit nannte der heutige tag der leuten
und der ist ein starkes zeichen für das
festhalten an traditionen und der
bereitschaft zum aufbruch zu neuen
aufgaben
ich bin froh dass wir heute alle an
diesem besonderen tag den tag der leute
begehen können und sei es auch unter
besonderen auflagen
es soll ein tag sein an denen sich die
hier angetreten leute ein leben lang mit
freude erinnern ein tag an dem sie mit
stolz an die absolvierung ihrer
offiziersausbildung zurückdenken ein tag
der für sie einen markstein in ihrem
leben darstellt ab dem sie in ihr
berufsleben einsteigen und neue
verantwortung übernehmen werden
wir soldaten sind zu recht dafür bekannt
und auch bereit uns auch unter
inkaufnahme von einschränkungen auflage
änderungen einzustellen aber wir
verfolgen unser ziel und lassen uns
nicht unterkriegen
diese eigenschaft die uns soldaten so
besonders auszeichnet wird nun auch vom
österreichischen bundesheer als ganzes
eingefordert das österreichische
bundesheer befindet sich zurzeit in
einer phase der beurteilung zum zweck
der neuausrichtung seiner aufgaben und
strukturen ja wir sind bereit uns
zukünftigen herausforderungen zu stellen
und uns entsprechend anzupassen
aber ich versichere ihnen wir werden das
große ziel die verfassungsmäßigen
aufgaben des österreichischen
bundesheeres niemals aus den augen
verlieren
ich erlaube mir an dieser stelle
wiederholt und mit nachdruck fest zu
halten und ich weiß mit unserem
oberbefehlshaber der bundespräsidentin
und unserer ressortleitung in
übereinstimmung das österreichische
bundesheer ist der sicherheitsgarant der
republik um seine aufgaben zu erfüllen
bedarf es neben gut ausgebildeten
personal auch einer zeitgemäßen
ausrüstung ohne diese dringend
erforderlichen investitionen kann das
bundesheer die bevor
folgerung gegen die zu erwartenden
bedrohungen nicht schützen gefährdet die
eigenen soldaten und kann die
verfassungsmäßig festgeschriebenen
verpflichtungen nicht mehr erfüllen
wir sind es unserer bevölkerung schuldig
die erfüllung dieser berechtigten
forderungen mit nachdruck einzumahnen
und ich sage das bewusst im angesichts
unserer neuen offiziere die in wenigen
minuten ihren drei der republik
österreich bis in den tod zu dienern
ablehnen werden geschätzte leutnant der
des jahrgangs hauptmann neusser in den
vergangenen drei studienjahren haben sie
sich ihrer persönlichen berufung folgend
auf einem beruf vorbereitet der dem
frieden und der sicherheit unserer
heimat und der freiheit sowie dem
wohlergehen unserer mitmenschen dient
sie haben sich damit entschieden ihr
leben den dienst an der gemeinschaft an
unserem volk und unserer republik
österreich zu widmann wozu ich ihnen
meinen besonderen respekt aussprechen
seien sie sich bewusst dass sie sich
auch in zukunft weiter bilden müssen und
durch städte übung und erfahrung zu
einem verantwortungsbewussten offizier
heranwachsen werden die zu fordere ich
sie auf stets bereit zu sein neues
aufzunehmen und in bescheidenheit und
demut die zusammenarbeit mit ihren
mitarbeitern zu pflegen
nur so werden sie es schaffen die in ihn
gesteckten ziele zu erreichen und ihre
aufträge entsprechend zu erfüllen
sie haben hauptmann karl neusser zu
ihrem jahrgangs patron und seinen namen
zu jahrgangs namen gewählt die wahl
eines offiziers der obwohl mit seiner
kompanie vom rest seines regiments
abgeschnitten auf eigene initiative
einen mutigen gegenstoß gegen den
feindlichen angriff führen tausende
seiner kameraden von der sicheren
schließung bewahrte scheint mir wohl
überlegt belegt diese wahl doch eine der
herausragendsten tugenden des offiziers
nämlich den blick für das ganze stets
vor augen im sinne der absicht seines
kommandanten entsprechend initiativ und
mutig zu
wie sie alle sehr gut wissen hat sich im
vergangenen halben jahr das wirkungs
bild des österreichischen bundesheeres
in der öffentlichkeit das heißt bei
unserer bevölkerung stark verändert war
in den ersten jahrzehnten seines
bestehens die militärische
landesverteidigung im mittelpunkt der
wahrnehmung der bevölkerung gestanden
ich erinnere nur an die großen raum
verteidigungs übungen im freien gelände
auch unter heranziehung von großen
teilen unserer miliz organisation zurück
in den vergangenen jahren zusätzlich
zusehens assistenzeinsätze vor allem
katastrophen assistenzen in den
blickpunkt der bevölkerung
der klimawandel sowie weltweite
migrationsbewegungen erforderten
weitgehende unterstützung und hilfe
leistungen zum wohle der bevölkerung und
ihrer sicherheit und bauern unvermindert
an
seit kurzem aber profiliert sich unser
bundesheer als tatsächliche strategische
reserve der republik österreich
man könnte fast glauben das bundesheer
macht alles und kann alles was andere
nicht mehr können
ja wir helfen überall nach kräften meine
damen und herren wo man uns braucht aber
vergessen sie nicht meine damen und
herren leuten hatte dass wir dies nur
können solange wir auch zu unseren
militärischen aufgaben befähigt sind nur
wenn wir unsere militärischen
kernaufgaben welcher waffengattung noch
immer beherrschen wird es auch künftig
werden wir auch künftig helfen können wo
andere es eben nicht mehr können
auch sie werden vielleicht schon nächste
woche bei ihrem neuen verband eine
assistenz aufgabe übernehmen müssen
bedenken sie dabei dass aus den soldaten
ausmacht seine loyalität disziplin und
ordnung dass führenden strafen
strukturen seine autarkie und
selbstständigkeit sein
durchhaltevermögen und die fähigkeit
lageangepasst rasch und zielstrebig auch
in die gefahr hin einzuhandeln
benötigten allen einsätzen im krieg in
der krise im friedensdienst
so wie bei schutz und tiefs aufgaben zum
wohle der bevölkerung
ich erwarte von ihnen dass sie alle
persönlichen fähigkeiten und jene
fertigkeiten die sie im rahmen der
ausbildung an der theresianischen
militärakademie erworben haben gepaart
mit einem respektvollen führungsstil in
ihren kommenden dienst einfließen lassen
begegnen sie ihren vorgesetzten
kameraden und untergebenen mit respekt
und achtung wenn man sie sich die zeit
den ihnen anvertrauten soldaten
zuzuhören sich vor sie zu stellen wenn
diese ihres schutzes bedürfen und seien
sie immer ein vorbild an soldatischer
tugend und haltung ich meine damit auch
führen sie ihre soldaten initiativ und
so wie es ihnen ihr namenspatron einst
vorgemacht hat stets von vorne
ich gratuliere ihnen zur erfolgreichen
absolvierung der offiziersausbildung und
der damit verbundene beförderung zum
leutnant des österreichischen
bundesheeres
ich wünsche ihnen den erwarteten
beruflichen erfolg gesundheit und
benötige kraft sowie persönliche
erfüllung bei den vor ihnen liegenden
aufgaben im dienste unserer heimat der
republik österreich und ihrer
bevölkerung ist lebe der jahrgang
hauptmann neuester es lebe die
theresianischen militärakademie
es lebe das österreichische bundesheer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrter herr bundespräsident sehr
geehrte exzellenzen hohe geistlichkeit
segeberg generalstabschef sehr geehrte
ehren und festgäste allen voran
sehr geehrte absolventen des jahrgangs
hat man neusser sehr geehrte leutnant es
ist mir eine große freude an diesem
besonderen tag hier bei ihnen zu sein
gemeinsam mit ihren angehörigen ihren
freunden und einem fest und ehrengästen
es sind sie die 53 berufs und die 24
miliz ihre die als leutnant heute im
mittelpunkt dieser militärischen feier
stehen an einem geschichtsträchtigen das
seit über 250 jahren der ausbildung der
offiziere in diesem land österreich
dient freue mich aber auch hier selbst
das erste mal als
verteidigungsministerin sein zu dürfen
auf den festplatz der theresianischen
militärakademie und diesen festtag mit
ihnen gemeinsam zu begehen sie meine
sehr geehrten herrn leitner haben die
größte hürde ihre bisherigen
militärischen laufbahn mit bravour
gemeistert
darauf können sie zu recht stolz sein
und doch stehen jetzt wieder sehr viele
neue herausforderungen vor ihnen
denn als offiziere des österreichischen
bundesheeres leben sie eine gewisse
ambivalenz arriva lenz zwischen zwei der
mit drei unterschiedlichen aufgaben zu
führen und zu dienen
sie führen unsere soldaten und dienen
dem volk als absolventen dieser
geschichtsträchtigen bildungseinrichtung
denen sie den freund jedoch nicht nur
sie gehen dem volk und insbesondere
ihren anvertrauten kameraden als
vorbilder auch stets voran und nicht nur
das sie stellen sich auch schützend
vor das volk dass meine sehr geehrten
leutnant das zeichnet sie als soldaten
und insbesondere als menschen aus sie
stehen am beginn ihrer laufbahn als
militärische experten und als
führungspersonen für aufgaben die
oftmals über das militärische
hinausgehen werden und glauben sie mir
sie werden sehr schnell die
verantwortung die sie nun zu tragen
haben spüren
aber unser bundesheer erwartet sie schon
dringend denken wir gemeinsam zurück als
sie vor drei jahren ihre ausbildung hier
begonnen haben
die welt damals die welt damals war eine
ganz andere
die republik österreich die staaten der
europäischen union ja die ganze welt
befindet sich in einer krise die durch
die folgen einer pandemie ausgelöst
wurde die staatlichen institutionen und
die wirtschaft geraten punktuell an die
grenzen ihrer leistungsfähigkeit
schon davor ja doch während der
einsetzenden corona krise hörten wir
immer wieder rufe das bundeswehr kann er
seine aufgaben nicht mehr erfüllen
und jetzt inmitten dieser krise frage
ich sie
welche aufgabe
hat unser heer nicht erfüllt gerade in
der korona krise haben wir bewiesen wozu
wir fähig sind um soja dank seiner
hervorragenden führungskräfte mehr
geschafft als ihm zugetraut wurde
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten haben
1,5 millionen stunden im cockpit einsatz
geleistet gleichzeitig unsere aufgaben
im ausland im bereich migration und bei
katastrophen bravourös gemeistert und
auch auf ein faktum können sie besonders
stolz sein
erstmals in der geschichte der republik
haben wir teile der miliz aufgeboten um
den menschen in diesem land rasch und
effektiv zu helfen
und der grund warum wir das alles
geschafft haben liegt vor allem an einem
faktor der oftmals vergessen wird es
liegt an den menschen
es liegt er den menschen aus denen das
bundesheer besteht
das sind offiziere vision offiziere
chancen und zivilbedienstete sie haben
bewiesen dass das bundesheer
einsatzfähig ist und für die bevölkerung
da ist wenn es gebraucht wird
sie hatte die leute nannte die
bundesregierung der bundesregierung und
der bevölkerung ich bewusst dass das
österreichische bundesheer über
militärische kernfähigkeiten verfügen
muss und ich verrate ihnen kein
geheimnis wenn ich sage was bisher jäger
bundesminister gefordert war
den für das bundesheer erforderlichen
anteil am budget der republik österreich
zu erhalten
das ringen und budget anteile wird aber
nicht dadurch unterstützt dass sein sohn
mit manchmal überzogener wortwahl den
untergang des bundesheeres prophezeien
viel jahr wissen wir alle
die offiziere des bundesheeres wir alle
gemeinsam die leistungen des jahres jahr
vorstellen und den wert dieser
institution für die gesamte republik für
die österreicherinnen und österreicher
lassen sie mich ein paar fakten
ansprechen
sie haben mit dem herrn
bundespräsidenten und mit mir einen
oberbefehlshaber und eine ministerin und
der spitze des jahres die sich für ein
starkes jahresbudget eingesetzt haben
und auch einsetzen werden den erfolg
erkennen sie daran dass gegenüber dem
vorjahr eine steigerung des budgets um
fast zehn prozent möglich geworden ist
darüber hinaus konnten wir gemeinsam
eine miliz paket im wert von
zusätzlichen 200 millionen euro
sicherstellen diesen kurs werden wir
fortsetzen dafür werden wir uns immer
stark machen darauf können sie sich
verlassen aber bereits das budget dieses
jahres hat wichtige und notwendige
beschaffungsentscheidungen ermöglicht
die die sicherheit österreichs
verbessern
im militärischen kernbereich werden uns
künftig 30 grad panzerband uhr 18
bewarfen barre mehrzweckhubschrauber
leistungsfähige gefechtsköpfe für
flieger abwehr lenkwaffen neue
handfeuerwaffen moderne nachtsicht
bringen und anderes mehr verstärken für
soldatinnen und soldaten werden 65.000
neue tarnanzüge andere uniformen 19.000
abc schutzanzügen hunderttausend feld
stiefel und vieles andere mehr beschafft
und jagte mobilität wird auch durch den
zulauf von 200 wechsel aufbauten zum
mannschaftssport und durch sechs moderne
großen busse gestärkt darüber hinaus
werden signifikante beträge in der
haltung und verbesserung der baulichen
und it-infrastruktur aufgewendet
ja und allein in die modernisierung und
sanierung der kasernen investieren wir
heuer rund 120 millionen euro
es wird also bereits vieles getan
die schon erwähnte budgeterhöhung
erlaubt mit augenmaß weitere
erneuerungen und verbesserungen im
bundesheer sowohl im kernbereich der
militärische landesverteidigung als auch
dort wo ich die bevölkerung derzeit am
dringendsten braucht meine sehr geehrten
leugnende sie werden wenn sie am montag
in ihren dienst in der truppe antreten
spüren dass unser heer gerade vor einem
großen sprung steht vor einem strom den
wir gemeinsam mit viel rückenwind machen
werden den rückenwind sehr geehrte damen
und herren den bekommen wir nunmehr von
der bevölkerung einer bevölkerung die in
der aktuellen krise sieht wie wichtig
ein schnelles und flexibles und ein
starkes heer ist das zeigt nach aktuelle
umfragen in denen das böse an der
dritten stelle vertrauenswürdiger
organisationen der republik steht und
diesen rückenwind
diesen rückenwind werden wir alle
brauchen denn wir müssen unser heer
bereitmachen bereit für die drängendsten
herausforderungen da gegenwart seines
blackouts terrorangriffe
naturkatastrophen oder auch pandemien
wie wir sie gerade erleben müssen aber
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
eines muss uns sehr wohl bewusst sein
die vorbereitung auf solche sehr
wahrscheinlichen risiken kosten viel
geld
geld das vielfach erst gesichert werden
muss aber das heißt nicht dass wir auf
unsere originären aufgaben vergessen
dürfen denn wer verteidigen kann kann
auch helfen ja nur helfen kann kam nicht
verteidigen daher muss es immer auch
unser anspruch sein österreich als
neutrales land im herzen europas
militärisch adäquat auf stabile beine zu
stellen
und das bedeutet dass wir auch in diesen
bereich weiter investieren müssen um die
erforderlichen militärischen kern
kompetenzen und fähigkeiten zu erhalten
daraus folgt wir werden noch mehr in die
bereiche cyber abwehr drohnen abwehr abc
abwehr und im bereich terrorabwehr
investieren gleichzeitig müssen wir
vorsorge treffen unser bundesheer in
teilbereichen insbesondere im fernen
betrieb autark und krisenfester zu
machen und auch im bereich der
ausbildung müssen wir uns
weiterentwickeln
ein beispiel dafür ist dass wir nun an
der einführung eines zweiten
studienganges an der theresianischen
militärakademie arbeiten im mittelpunkt
dieser ausbildung soll neben der
militärischen führung auch die kt
elektronische kampfführung und sauber
stehen ich freue mich darauf ihnen in
den kommenden monaten den
bachelorstudiengang militär informatik
präsentieren zu können
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
leugnende den wir die großen
herausforderungen gemeinsam an die
bevölkerung verlässt sich auf unser
lehrer und verlässt sich auf sie migros
beweise was du kannst appelliere ich an
sie zeigen sie dem bundesheer und dem
volk was sie gelernt haben
seien sie mutig fordern sie sich selbst
und ihre mitarbeiter und verlieren sie
nie
den anspruch immer besser zu werden
seien sie auch mutig in der art und
weise wie sie denken indem sie weiter
denken und geistige schranken
niederreißen die sie in ihrer
persönlichen entwicklung und uns in der
weiterentwicklung des heeres limitieren
suchen sie aber immer auch das
gemeinsame dann nur dann wenn ihnen das
gelingt werden wir gemeinsam unser herr
wieder stärker schneller und
schlagkräftiger machen können
abschließend abschließend möchte ich
meinen dank an ihre eltern lebenspartner
ihre freunde und ihre familie richten
denn auch sie tragen die folgenreiche
persönliche entscheidung dem eigenen
land als offiziere zu dienen mit sehr
geehrte angehörige ich danke ihnen
herzlich für die unterstützung die sie
persönlich diesen männern und frauen im
dienste der republik österreich geben
sehr geehrte leutnant miliz und
berufsoffizier ich gratuliere ihnen zur
erfolgreichen absolvierung der
offiziersausbildung und der damit
verbundenen beförderung zum leutnant sie
beginnen nun einen neuen abschnitt in
ihrer militärischen laufbahn sie treten
ein in neue zeiten
dazu wünsche ich ihnen erfolg und
erfüllung und das hierzu notwendige
soldatenglück nicht nur die gruppe
österreich wartet auf sie das leben der
jahrgang hat mein neues leben die
theresianischen militärakademie
es lebe das österreichische bundesheer
es lebe die republik
sehr geehrte damen und herren es erfolgt
nun die ansprache des herrn
bundespräsidenten und die verleihung des
offiziers an den jahrgangs ersten des
jahrganges hauptmann meister leiter und
bernd denninger
[Musik]
sehr geehrte frau bundesministerin sehr
geehrter herr generalstabschef sehr
geehrte ehren und festgäste
aber wenn besonderer gruß ist den damen
und herren lloyd nannte die heute in das
bundesheer übernommen werden dieser tag
beendet einen langen und hohe
anforderungen stellen den ausbildungsweg
den sie erfolgreich zurückgelegt haben
dazu gratuliere ich ihnen herzlich
meine damen und herren ich lese ihnen
kurz etwas vor
ich zieh dir eine pandemie ist die
unkontrollierte ausbreitung einer hoch
ansteckenden infektionskrankheit die
nicht eingedämmt werden kann im
extremfall dürften die menschen ihre
häuser nicht verlassen es käme zu
massiven versorgungsengpässen die
krankenhäuser sanitätszelt rennen und
mobilen wo die medizinischen dienste
wären überfordert
sie werden sich jetzt wundern dass ich
ihnen etwas in der möglichkeitsform
vorgelesen habe in der möglichkeitsform
obwohl die realität ja schon erlebt
haben
ich habe aber gerade aus dem bericht
unser herr 2030 zitiert der vor gut
einem jahr erstellt und publiziert
worden ist
in diesem bericht werden auch andere
risiken wie etwa angriffe oder blackouts
dargestellt und so wie uns die kogit 19
pandemie überrascht hat können
vielfältige bedrohungen von einem tag
auf den anderen unseren alltag auf den
kopf stellen
die bewältigung dieser bedrohungen
erfordert ein gesamtstaatliches handeln
und ich betone dass und ein
einsatzfähiges österreichisches
bundesheer
daher begrüße ich es sehr dass nun ein
transparenter und parlamentarisch
begleitet der prozess zur entwicklung
der streitkräfte auf basis eines
evidenzbasierten risiko bildes
eingeleitet wurde
am ende dieses prozesses soll nicht nur
ein klarer reformplan stehen der das
österreichische bundesheer fit für die
herausforderungen des 21 jahrhunderts
macht selbstverständlich müssen auch die
notwendigen finanziellen mittel
bereitgestellt werden um das bundesheer
zur bewältigung aktueller bedrohungen
und damit zum schutz der
österreicherinnen und österreicher und
aller menschen die hier leben zu
befähigen
sehr geehrte angehörige des
österreichischen bundesheers in den
dreieinhalb jahren meiner amtszeit habe
ich einen sehr guten eindruck von ihnen
und ihren fähigkeiten geworden
von der hohen motivation der soldatinnen
und soldaten vom ausgezeichneten
ausbildungsstand von ihrer
einsatzbereitschaft zur bewältigung
ihrer aufgaben ist es unabdingbar sie
mit der notwendigen ausrüstung
auszustatten
ansonsten ist ja nicht nur die
aufgabenerfüllung sondern das leben der
soldatinnen und soldaten bei ihren
einsätzen gefährdet ich danke allen für
ihren täglichen einsatz besonders der
ihnen die derzeit in krisengebieten im
ausland ihren dienst versehen und im
assistenzeinsatz im inland stehen
meine damen und herren liebe nannte der
namensgeber ihres jahrgangs hauptmann
karl neusser zeichnete sich durch
mutiges initiatives handeln in einer
scheinbar ausweglosen situation aus
initiative das persönliche führen von
vorne das überlegte und bewusste handel
und hohe soziale kompetenz sind
essentielle fähigkeiten für jeden
offizier das geben von befehlen ist
einfach viel schwieriger ist es seine
soldaten zu motivieren wie diese
fürsorglich verfügbar und ein vorbild zu
sein
nehmen sie dabei die unterstützung der
unteroffiziere und offiziere in ihren
zukünftigen tätigkeitsbereichen
meine damen und herren leuten könnte
sie beenden mit dem heutigen tag ihre
ausbildung an der militärakademie
ich danke an dieser stelle dem
lehrpersonal dass sie auf die vor ihnen
stehenden herausforderungen bestens
vorbereitet hat sie werden in den
unterschiedlichsten funktionen
verantwortung übernehmen
sie werden national und auch
international dazu beitragen dass
frieden und sicherheit in unserer heimat
und in europa erhalten bleiben
sie bekennen sich zu den demokratischen
werten und haben gelernt als offiziere
stets den menschen in den mittelpunkt
ihres denkens und handelns zu stellen
und ich darf ihnen heute dafür danken
dass sie als berufsoffiziere unserer
republik dienen
ich danke heute auch den leute nannten
des miliz standes die bereits und neben
dem zivilen beruf freiwillig sehr viel
zeit zu investieren um zum schutz der
österreichischen bevölkerung beizutragen
es wird mir nun eine ehre sein den von
ihr gestifteten ehren säbel dem
jahrgangs ersten leutnant weniger
stellvertretend für den gesamten
ausmusterung jahrgang zu überreichen
ihnen ein wünsche ich alles gute und
viel erfolg in ihrem beruf und vor allem
wünsche ich dem österreichischen
bundesheer und unserem land dass europa
ein kontinent des friedens bleiben möge
es lebe das österreichische bundesheer
es lebe unsere heimat die republik
österreich
es lebe unser gemeinsames
[Applaus]
weniger minuten fanden sich am 7
es ist mir eine große freude ihnen
erläutert weniger in ehren säbel zu
überreichen
sie waren der jahrgangs erste und sie
übernehmen das stellvertretend für alle
damen und herren leute nannte die heute
ihre ausbildung beenden danke vielmals
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir kommen nun zum höhepunkt des
heutigen festaktes den tennis der leiden
weil der jahrgangssprecher des jahrgangs
hauptmann neuester leiten und oliver
seidl mit dass trebnitz verlesen nach
den darauf folgenden marsch oder in
österreich erfolgte sie bieten weitere
befehle
offiziere spricht mir nach ich gelobe
mein vaterland die republik österreich
und sein volk zu schützen und mit der
waffe zu verteidigen
richtig loben den gesetzen und
gesetzmäßig behörden treue und gehorsam
zu leisten
alle befehle meiner vorgesetzten
künstlich und genau zu befolgen und mit
allen meinen kräften der republik
österreich
und in österreich ist ein volk zu dienen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren der kommenden
star auswirkungen gruppe wird nun das
ende des festaktes melden und dem
anschluss wird der information aus
marschieren
ich darf sie bitten am zugewiesenen
sitzplatz zu verbleiben und dem nach dem
ausmarsch burgen den anweisungen zum
geordneten verlassen des
veranstaltungsortes folge zu leisten
[Musik]